[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys and
we have in the seat today mr chappelle
hey
[Laughter]
ah
i don't get mixed up
do people go oh wait you're
a different chappelle like i was looking
for the other chappelle you know not not
necessarily i usually get
get it at like um i got like a starbucks
people will say [ __ ] like are you
related yeah yeah yeah
it's like it's like yo i gave you my
first name
did you ever ask your mom like
why
did you name me in the shadow of someone
else
yeah how old are you i was born in 87.
i'm 35. oh okay okay yeah so like he
wasn't you know i mean i think he
probably just had started comedy or
whatever but uh
no no uh it was um
a friend of hers
his name was chappelle
and that's how that's where it came from
okay yeah yeah i was just thinking for a
second she was like an early underground
comedy groupie that'd be funny
she had to be in her teens then because
i think chappelle started when he was
like 14 or something in the comic club
um
when i was born though my mom was how
old was my mom i think she was 22 when i
was born there was yeah she was 22. she
was born in the 60s yeah 65. so she so
she named you after a friend
would you guys name
your kids after me
i think you guys just let me know how
tight you are
i think i would have an intervention
with bart if he was going to do that we
got to really think about this his
legacy is going to be affected
i don't have a cool name like chappelle
my name is joe that's a very unique name
so it's just too common man it's very
biblical that's why is chappelle your
first name or last name first name first
name what's your last name i go by lacey
chapelle lacy chapelle yeah lacey's my
middle name harris is my last name but i
don't
know
[Laughter]
so how did you connect with bart
um i saw him i actually uh yeah what was
yeah i saw you on the explore page and
then uh you were telling this joke about
how um what was it oh you felt sorry for
poor white people because poor blacks
have talent right oh no no no i didn't
say it like that oh look at how [ __ ]
good
they don't know you know
we're original
he literally butchered that whole
sorry i just want bart to redo
i'm
joke
everybody's yeah
so whatever yeah go ahead try it again
do an impersonation of him doing the
video
mine
the way that my stupid brain turned
was uh
what poor white people have it the
hardest because they don't have talent
and so they can't make it out yeah
same thing you said before just keep on
the joke no the joke is is i grew up
around a lot of white people and the
white people i grew up around were we
were all poor yeah and so uh yeah but
the guys i grew up with specifically
not saying poor white people don't have
talent there's four white people that
are talented uh they don't they could
play something
so but i know yeah barnes is like yeah
white people suck it's like any place
especially if they're poor no the guys i
grew up with specifically
they were poor and they just
they just they couldn't do anything yeah
so that that's who that joke is about
you didn't have that one poor white
friend with the overalls and no t-shirt
and then the banjo and then like that's
pretty talented it was arizona i grew up
in arizona
i grew up in arizona
what did you say you grew up in arizona
i grew up in arizona so like if we
didn't have any banjos or anything like
that
we have we have no banjo state yeah no
banjo state yeah
it's a it's a guitar state yeah where i
grew up with a lot of myths
so it was either method
so none of those white people were good
at mess
thought he sucked at that too
can you give me a favor can you write
jokes for bart and then we'll see how he
is
loved it
the way he said i was like like i just
hate white people
you don't put professional [ __ ]
bodybuilders on the stage
that's a great intro like dude this
guy's chappelle coming up he hates what
let's bring him on
let's keep it going for chapelle
somebody's trying to correct them only
poor ones yeah only poor ones guys
sometimes you have to break down your
jokes it's crazy
[Laughter]
yeah yeah i know yeah
what's what's another joke of his you've
seen bart that was the first time i saw
this guy
when you saw it look she hates white
people
[Laughter]
we gotta bring him on the show
and here i am
hey guys i found the guy that'll fit
right in with us
no yeah what if you find out you're not
a comedian you just hate wiping it
i just went on stage to do that yeah
i just took the mic you know
something yeah and then i remember david
went on the podcast with you and brendan
and then i was like oh yeah
yeah yeah oh cool we're like all just
like a degree apart yeah exactly and
then uh i think you know
my boy toby toby morris
oh uh yeah he he talks with my wife and
they do a bunch of like artsy stuff
together okay i thought i do follow him
okay yeah he's already like 20 22 for
drugs like what is that yeah what's up
does that mean does that mean she's
blowing him
rtrt
rtrt rt rtrt
do anything artsy with my rtrt i'll
[ __ ] kill you
how about that
barton explains things i'm crazy bro
it does not stick up for himself i
didn't do well in english i just made up
a telephone game
what got you into comedy uh someone
dared me really yeah that was it
and he just like fell in love with it he
kept going yeah yeah was his name dave
open mic setting where he's like get up
there uh no some uh when i
when i was living in uh louisville
kentucky
uh that's where i was i was a
competitive cheerleader and i was
cheering in college
you could do crazy flips and [ __ ] yeah
yeah oh yeah you can launch people in
the sky you can hold this thing with one
girl
and then twist them down the guy if you
say your cheerleader you better be funny
right
you have to fight i think that yeah
that's how they have to be right
physical phenomenon yeah
um but yeah so uh my buddies used to
play these acoustic nights
at uh at a bar
and one night they called me up i was
like really drunk and you know they're
just like come on come up here and you
know talk or whatever and i just told a
story and people were laughing at the
story and then uh someone's like yo man
you should do comedy and i was like i
don't know [ __ ] about comedy but the
kind of drunk i was was the kind of
drunk that was like say i won't
yeah
i was
and uh
and everybody knew that and uh my buddy
was like you won't do comedy i was like
say i won't and then
literally like
i want to say i study i studied comedy
for like a month how did you study
comedy i just watched comedy i just
watched it because i didn't really know
anything about like i didn't think of
comedy as like anybody could do it
because like the comedy i knew was eddie
murphy raw
uh dave chappelle's killing him softly
and then uh kings of comedy so those
were those were just golden ears but i
thought
because i knew them for acting as well
so like i thought like i was like oh
those guys do that you know that's the
thing that they do like i didn't think
like anybody could just i didn't know
there was like a way to get into comedy
yeah so anyways i just watched it and
then
signed up for open mic somewhere in
kentucky and then went up and i was like
man this is dope and then i just dropped
out of college and was like yeah it's
[ __ ]
let's let's ride it because all because
you got drunk one night
can you do me a favor if when you make
it can you just think alcohol for a day
oh yeah yeah
everyone likes to shell over alcohol
it's like hey man thank you alcohol
alcohol is the reason why i'm here or
thank your friends for having positive
dares yeah you [ __ ] yeah what do i do to
start a business
they could have said anything
i dare you to get out the slums you're
on that fine line they could have said
anything they could have been like i bet
you won't beat up that dude over there
i'll get in jail dude
hey do the crate challenge
what's funny is i never i never thought
of it like that so shout out to alcohol
yeah i got i gotta even though i've been
off it for eight years i gotta i gotta
give it up for it
shout out to .08 man i'm surprised your
friends didn't dare you to do like a
backflip or something no no cause it was
friends i cheered with i chewed with
these guys they all could do it
they're never gonna actually go back
with this like they do every day at
universe the opposite's happening
yeah there's something funny about just
saying these guys i cheered with
[Laughter]
these guys i cheered with
professional shirt is crazy oh yeah i
did yeah like competitions in florida
and stuff like that yeah [ __ ] bananas
it looks like gymnastics and dancing
they got a baby with yeah yeah it's
crazy uh [ __ ] acrobats yeah today's
video is brought to you by hello tushy
one of the easiest bidets to use and i
love bidets because it keeps your butt
super clean
super fresh and i'm one of those people
where if my butt feels itchy
it bothers me the whole day and i have
to take a shower but then it also takes
time out of the day so i like having a
bidet because it just cleans my butt
after i poop and then i feel nice and
clean and it's cool because you go one
way and it sprays your bottle and they
go the other way it actually sprays the
nozzle that's supposed to spray your
butthole because it cleans it
it's pretty cool also you know what when
you start using the bidet
eighty percent of toilet paper use is
not being used so that means you save
more money on toilet paper and it also
installs in less than eight minutes you
don't even need electrician you don't
need a plumber so it's super easy to do
yourself very easy so we want all of our
listeners to have clean bums just like
us visit hellotushy.com off the record
to get ten percent off plus free
shipping right now tag us and at hello
tissue so we can celebrate your clean
bum with you that's hello tissue.com off
the record for 10 percent ah how did you
get into cheer someone else dared you
[Laughter]
also sam will do cheerleading
oh that wasn't so good
oh no i had a crush on this girl man yes
yeah that's all it starts
sorry that's all you need runs the world
was she on the cheer team yeah she was
on the true team
but he's been off girls for eight
[Laughter]
years yeah
no yeah this girl uh i went to school
with
i had a big crush on her i played in a
ska band with her brother oh it means
you guys are doing art [ __ ] huh
did you play in the skyband i played
bass
but uh yeah so she um
i originally i taught myself how to do
backflips when i was like five so i just
knew how to do all these slips five yes
on your parents bed
no no outside on like park benches and
[ __ ] you know just started like flipping
and then uh i just kept doing it and i
just got like better and better at it
and then uh
one day we were like in some field or
something like just all hanging out it
was after like a church group thing what
did they call those
um wednesday nights
no it's like community no it's like
a bible study bible study yeah you know
what are they called those what is that
damn thing wrong answers
yeah
because they lure in with something else
like some kind of barbecue or like a
dodge ball yeah you have to go do bible
study yeah yeah yeah
with dodgeball
they do here with like random [ __ ] so
we're like oh this looks fun so you
don't think about that first yeah the
cool thing so
she uh
she was like doing flips in the field or
whatever and then i was like i know how
to do that too and then
i showed her and she was like oh my god
you want to join cheer with me and i was
like yeah
[ __ ] you thing yeah right anything
of course she's like you want to go beat
up that guy position yeah when you're in
this position you're like i got to make
sure she's stable
oh that's the best too
like how can you build more trust than
that like that's the ultimate choice she
got me into it and uh i just didn't get
into it though like dude no no wait did
i get into what
her you know oh no that never happened
never happened
happened shout out to her though she she
did
save my life and you know you guys still
friends yeah yeah she's really yeah
dive into that real quick
save your life in a sort of way
i have been noticing every explanation
gets more interesting than the other
it's like how did you get into comedy i
was a cheerleader how'd you get into
that i played in a base in a ska band
and then someone saved my life you know
what i think it is bart i think he knows
how to tell a story
it's almost like he's a professional
comedian he doesn't start with so
i hate white people
although that is interesting
it's a good it's a good one we all
leaned in when he said that yeah
everyone everyone's like okay you hate
white people we all showed up but then
we had to go to bible study
you know what what would make it better
though if you were like i hate white
everyone'll be people ah that's cool
give me a w
it gives me your life that's so
interesting uh
you know she brought me into a positive
environment you know i i grew up pretty
crazy i grew up on an abusive uh
stepfather it's always step fathers but
uh
you know meal is my actual biological
thing
you better one up break down
break the stigma
[Laughter]
thank you alcohol yeah
no and uh i was just i was such a nut i
was just crazy man and
you know fighting and doing all just
doing all the wrong [ __ ] in a way mainly
just because of you know how i was
treated at home
so
that was the first time i ever saw like
something
positive like knew that there was
something positive in the world was when
she got me into cheerleading that's
amazing so it was like so she so that's
how she pretty much
helped me and i give her a lot of credit
still to this day people do say like
competitiveness athleticism or some kind
of arts or hobby
is a gateway out of like a lot of uh you
know struggles in the home and stuff
yeah yeah like it's a different level of
like discipline like
you know because i did skateboarding and
you know playing the band stuff but
there's no coach to that
you when you have a when you have a
coach
you have someone telling you hey you're
doing this wrong or hey you you oh that
was good you did this and you know blah
blah blah like having someone kind of
direct you in a way
to where
you kind of just take all the stuff in
and you know and can just apply it to
life in general
is like i think it's a dope thing you
know what i mean and i think that's what
uh
you know
i think that's what she kind of just i
don't know it just organically
helped me out with
the team aspect too is like such a big
thing yeah like working with people that
are just completely different than you
and you have to do this one thing
together and you have to understand and
you know kind of respect all these
different personalities
so i i don't know i love the world of
sports because of that because it does
teach you you know someone someone
yelling at you in a way because
you gotta think
there's tougher [ __ ] you're gonna deal
with
as an adult or you know as you you know
walk through life but some like a coach
yelling at you to to be better
is like the is the least of your words
that's why when i don't know if you guys
remember
there was this uh it happened with
marshawn lynch
where
i think he told the kid get get the [ __ ]
off my field you you messed up blah blah
blah and the mom i think had freaked out
and
but i'm like that's i mean that's what
you need that's what you need
because i was like i was like like he's
gonna be able to deal with
so much other [ __ ] if that's the if
that's you know that's like a safe space
to get abused yeah yeah exactly yeah in
a sense in a sense yeah it says
it has a benefit and also like i'm not
saying to just talk to people like talk
down on people and he's just and i don't
think he was talking down on the kid as
much as like you need to understand what
you did wrong and a lot of times people
do you know understand what the [ __ ]
they did wrong because when you get to
an adult and you don't understand it
it'll [ __ ] you up way more than when
you're a kid
that's you know that's why i love the
world of sports and what it did for me
my mom did the opposite like when we do
like uh open house whatever
the teacher of like all your son talks
too much in class you just hit me whack
what else you do
and the teacher would be like no no no
like that that's it i'm not gonna say
that
yeah tell me tell me everything yeah
straight a's you know they met before
they're like okay i'll be bad cops
he's conspired against you i never felt
like my mom got my back it was like
whatever the teacher said
she was gonna be the megaphone for that
oh yeah yeah yeah like if i got punished
at school then when we go home that's
extra but do the teachers treat you
different afterwards once they see your
mom beat you in front of them the next
day they're like extra nice to you they
are a little bit because they're like
your mom's awesome because they don't
want to be the
shout out to your mom thank you alcohol
alcohol what i was doing all her dad had
to do is take him to [ __ ] neiman
marcus
ethan allen
sorry sorry
steven
uh she bible studied you yeah
your
her barbecue was her vagina that you
were attracted to oh and as you thought
we were talking about bart's mom for a
second
you should have set that up better
you're still on that but that was a bar
though that was good yeah that was yeah
if you would have heard yeah
before bart's story were you were you
doing professional cheer in uh in
college yeah so i started yeah i started
at 15 and
i quit at 26. oh so you did all the
major competitions yeah
so you were doing it for a while yeah
quit
i was just [ __ ] i was like dude what
the [ __ ] am i doing
i'm all glitter i'm all glittered up at
26 years old what the [ __ ] she's like
bro i need to stop
i was like i didn't get her i didn't get
her all right
why am i still trying
she left
you ended up loving it yeah yeah i know
i did i i loved it i loved it man i just
yeah it was it was a big escape yeah
from uh
the world but also like
you know escape but i learned a lot
along the way like
you know because of joining cheerleading
i went through anger management
you know and anger management was
another thing that like saved my life
you know that's like a big i give like a
lot of credit to that as well
still you seem like such a calm guy man
it's hard to picture you as a
they did really good yeah
they're really good programs oh yeah no
i i mean because
man once once you
once you live a life of being so
crazy up here and then you find a way
and you start to see these ways like oh
you can live like this this other
perspective all of a sudden you just
like
you know and i'm like i don't want to
get [ __ ] crazy anymore like i just
rather just
[ __ ]
i don't let [ __ ]
fly the way it flies and [ __ ] i'll do
what i do cheer footage of him and he's
going get your [ __ ] together ever what
are you doing i don't think you
understand i used to be
a [ __ ]
at cheer practice bro you can [ __ ] up
around me yeah i would like like you
know like they say jordan would [ __ ]
not care for certain compare myself
you know i i would too like i was i mean
i was just [ __ ] reckless with
you know i'm like alana you [ __ ] up
you know what i mean but like oh dude i
used to get so crazy what would people
ever cry around you uh no i think people
were kind of used to it oh so they just
knew like yeah they just do like oh he's
just crazy he's a heartless he's a hard
ass and like everybody knew where i came
from so like they're none of them you
know i love them all to death and you
know some of them
said [ __ ] you to me some of them stuck
by my side but uh i think they just
understood like where i came from
and the
situation i was in prior to being where
i was at so there's like he's
like don't worry he's [ __ ]
a cheerleading
aggressive coach
movie
dude
like that's just a like whiplash but for
cheer
oh and i was i was i was a shitty cheer
coach i was like i can't do that i can't
coach that's exactly what the hollywood
market needs by the way yeah i know yeah
is that an aggressive chairman
coach what's wrong with what's wrong
with you oh i think just the fact that
this is so weird to say why am i talking
about you but uh this is actually this
is so we've never heard about this
everything he does is what we're about
okay
uh because i was really really really
[ __ ] good at it right and
i think i just expected people to get
[ __ ] as quick as i did and so just
because you started when you're five
technically well like well just doing
the flips and stuff but
um have you heard brady talk about how
he can't coach because of that basically
he doesn't think he can ever tom brady
yeah no because he's like i don't think
i could because i'm too impatient
yeah no that was my thing i had no
patience
that's why they say athletes really
don't make best coaches sometimes the
good ones the good athletes don't i mean
steve kerr oh steve definitely yeah yeah
he was good but i thought it's funny me
did steve kerr really name his son nick
yes that's we looked it up
wait what's the what's the mean about it
what's funny about this
oh no i probably shouldn't
[Music]
[Music]
you